well this week is big news in the world
of gold saudi funded live golf tour
heads to the trump national golf club in
new jersey tom's been accused of helping
to sanitize saudi arabia's international
image and 9 11 families united group the
viscerally both the defected governors
and the former president trump for
taking part but joining me now is john
daly a two-time major golf winner trump
friend and supporter and a great
character john daly what a pleasure to
have you on my show
thanks for having me pierce i love you
brother
thank you i love you brother too you
know there was a moment at the open in
scotland when you were walking past i
think you were wearing your hooters
trousers and i shouted your name and you
suddenly turned you didn't know it was
me you just turned and looked at a group
of people and you gave us a hilarious
smirk and a great wave and we all just
melted in awe at this great man doing
his thing
well
i love my fans man i've always loved
them i've always played for them and
you know wherever i've gone in the world
to play golf i've always had a home team
advantage and it's been awesome
for 30 something years it's just been
great
well you deserve it because you you give
a lot back to the fans i think and also
you play golf the way i play which is
you know have a beer have a game of golf
have a cigar maybe have a bit of fun
smile on your face but right now john
golf is going through a very difficult
fractious period between the official
pga tour and this rival live tour funded
by the saudis it's now come to uh
trump's cause he's up there he's been
promoting it what do you make of this
route how do you think it ends
well we'll find out in the long run but
i beg greg norman to let me be on the
live tour because
you know
we work really hard and i play with
brian harmon and practice around and
some other guys in the practice rounds
of the
british open it's like we play pro-ams
we get it okay that's what is the
backbone of a lot of our tournaments but
brian harmon says give us a box of
chocolates for the effort we make tent
visits we do this we do that i play two
to three programs every week on the
champions tour
and you know we don't play for a lot of
money on the champions tour so i almost
feel like okay i'm not getting a lot out
of this what what what are we doing look
i'd rather play with amber's than the
pros sometimes but
you know we've got to get compensated
for that and the live tour has given
players that
it's given you know they play pro-ams
it's a big party they play for a lot of
money which these guys that are on that
tour deserve that money and i think
there's a lot of other guys that deserve
that money especially this old man
what about the morality issue because i
i think and i wrote this for the new
york post there's a lot of hypocrisy
about morality in sport but a lot of the
pga sponsors for example do lots of
business in the middle east and so on uh
do you think there's a lot of hypocrisy
here
oh pierce let's not talk about that they
don't want to be mentioned in that
because you know of all the labor laws
and stuff you know what i'm saying it's
it's unbelievable the politics is so
stupid in this i could talk about nike i
could talk about other companies that
little eight and 13 year olds are
building shoes for nike okay we don't
want to get into that right you want to
talk about labor laws we're talking
about golf
guys that are playing golf it's an
international sport
jed the prince
of saudi arabia he's a great guy
um
and he's given so much money
to golfers that deserve it
well there's some that aren't deserving
because i should be on that tour yeah
why aren't you on the tour you'll be my
first
well greg says he's not doing any more
and i'm too old so
but let me go into entertainment and get
all my get all my friends to do the
concerts and stuff and let's you know
it's
playing with bryson shambo in the
british open i'm sorry the open
championship i can't say british anymore
but
uh was an eye-opener because he said
it's the greatest thing on earth we
still play a pro-am
it's two pros
two amateurs yeah it's what it should be
anyway you're done in four hours yeah
and we played for a lot of money which
we deserve to play for
but
you know i just wish
to sum this up i wish
every tour would get along where
everything can work out i think that you
know what glasgow is such a great game i
think that's the way it's going to go
they're going to have to do a deal
because so many top players are
defecting they're going to not have a
pga tour at this rate talk to me about
donald trump for a moment uh he's an old
friend of yours
a friend of mine um
what do you make of him what do you
think about him running again for
president would you endorse that
daddy trump is the greatest president we
ever had i go back to the reagan era and
bush senior
um
what he did
with kind of a a downfall of presidency
with obama nothing against obama but
um
daddy trump came in and what i love
about him
he said
everything that he was going to do
unfortunately the biden administration
did the opposite of what they said they
were going to do our country is in
shambles our middle class people are
starving they're not doing anything for
them and it just makes me sick
kamala hair is supposed to protect the
border she's been down there she went to
el paso to have drinks and a mexican
food
it's it saddens me
that
the way this administration is the whole
white house is so corrupt right now it's
all about them making money and we'll
worry about the american people later
donald trump never took a dime from the
american people never took a salary and
is one of the best presidents that ever
lived john we call this show piers
morgan uncensored for a reason because
we like uncensored guests you are an
uncensored guest great to talk to you
thank you very much
i love you and what you did for the
queen's jubilee
i couldn't take my eyes off the tv
your knowledge of her was so amazing in
the family thank you for that because i
got a new i got a new opening to
what the queen of royalty was all about
that's brilliant princess diane was
still alive i'd be
i would be married to her
john great to talk to you all the very
best to you
thank you see you buddy
you